good morning Hank it's Tuesday signing
update I am just past 135 thousand
signatures okay so ten years ago today
was one of the most important days of my
life Hank a long time ago you introduced
me to the idea that bad news usually
happens all at once whereas good news
usually happens slowly like part of the
reason we don't hear about the
continuing decline in absolute poverty
or childhood mortality or deaths by
violence is that they aren't events
right their processes that occur over
decades or centuries but from
earthquakes to shootings to car
accidents bad news is usually an event
like we all know the experience of going
about our daily lives and then BOOM out
of nowhere life-changing ly bad news
however that noted sometimes bad news
happens slowly climate change comes to
mind and good news happens all at once
like boom out of nowhere incredibly
happy news maybe you get a surprise a on
a test or an unexpected gift from a
friend or maybe it's something bigger
and when I think about this in my own
life there are five memories of shock -
joy that come to mind the first two are
the births of my children which I
suppose is not like technically
surprising because I did know it was
coming but both times the feeling was a
complete surprise this weird
overwhelmingness with a mix of joy and I
guess like all the third was in 2003
Sarah and I had been friends for a
couple years at that point and we were
hanging out one afternoon at her
apartment and she mentioned that she and
her boyfriend had broken up a couple
months earlier and I was like wait what
fourth it's January of 2006 Sarah and I
are living in New York were engaged and
were walking down the street on our way
to go register for wedding presents and
my parents happen to be in town so
they're with us and my dad happened to
have a camera and you have to remember
this is before everyone has like a
camera inside their phone right so I get
a phone call from a weird number and I
answer it and I learned that my first
novel Looking for Alaska has just won
the Michael L Printz award the biggest
award in young adult books and my dad
takes this picture of us as we're
finding out and lastly it's July of 2007
we've just moved from New York to
Indianapolis for Sara's job and we've
just bought our first house which is
really exciting but also really scary
because suddenly I have a mortgage and a
lawn to maintain and gutters to clean
and there are boxes everywhere and also
I literally had no fur
work is going okay my second book didn't
sell very well but I am doing this fun
year-long project with my brother called
Brotherhood 2.0 where we make videos
back and forth to each other every week
day a few hundred people watch every day
and it's a really creatively fulfilling
project but it hasn't even occurred to
me to keep going after the end of 2007
and then ten years ago today Hank you
upload a song about how excited you are
for the publication of the last Harry
Potter book it's called Akio Accio Akio
Bosch Kosh B'gosh EO Deathly Hallows and
it starts like this
I'm getting kind of tired of this
pre-publication media blitz you got all
of muggle kind undo you spell
don't you know the whole moons already
gone and reserved a copy at Amazon how
many more books could you sell when I
first see that video I just think wow
and I am NOT alone
lots of people like the song it gets
picked up on Harry Potter fan forms
which leads to our project being
discovered by a group of passionate
people who know how to build internet
communities and a couple days later the
song is featured on the front page of
YouTube and we go from around 200
YouTube subscribers to over 5,000 and
suddenly our year-long project starts to
feel like maybe it could last longer
than a year and here we are a decade
later so lucky to still be talking to
each other and to still have people
watching make without Accio Deathly
Hallows it's hard to know what our lives
would look like but they would look
different we wouldn't have met Esther or
the people who power the project for
awesome you probably wouldn't have
gotten to sing in front of thousands of
people and I highly doubt that I would
be in a position to sign 200,000 copies
of my new book so Hank thank you for
making that song and for giving me one
of my favorite memories and thanks to
everyone who watched it then and also
everyone who watches us now Hank I'll
see you on Friday